you said
2024 uh as it stands now are both the
first test launch and the launch of
Escapade explorers Tom Mars still
possible in4 yeah yeah I think so um for
sure the first launch and then we'll see
if if Escapade goes on that or not I
think that the first launch for sure and
I hope Escapade too hope well I just
don't know which Mission it's it's
actually going to be slated on so we
also have other things that might go on
that first mission oh I got it but
you're optimistic that uh the launches
will still oh the first launch I'm very
optimistic that the first launch of new
Glenn will be in 2024 and I'm just not
100% certain what payload will be on
that first launch are you nervous about
it are you kidding I'm extremely nervous
about
it oh man 100% I've you know every uh
every launch I go to uh you know for new
Shepherd for other vehicles too I'm
always nervous for these launches but
yes for sure a first launch to have no
nervousness about that would be you know
some sign of derangement I think so well
I got the visit the launch but it's
pretty um I mean it's epic you know we
have done a tremendous amount of ground
testing a tremendous amount of uh
simulation so uh you know a lot of the
problems that we might find in Flight
have been resolved but there are some
problems you can only find in flight so
you know cross your fingers I guarantee
you you'll uh you'll have fun watching
it no matter what happens 100% when the
thing is fully assembled and comes up
yeah the the transporter erector just
transporter erector for a rocket of this
scale is extraordinary that's an
incredible machine the vehicle uh
travels out horizontally and then kind
of you know comes up over a few hours
yeah it's a beautiful thing to
watch